the Joe Rogan experience well you know
we had talked about your dad and your
dad being in jail and of all people man
Kim Kardashian has had I think something
like 28 people wrongly accused released
from prison she's all about like prison
justice reform and she makes these
regular trips to the White House to talk
to the president about prison reform and
about getting people out of jail that
that got bad deals yeah and I mean
that's that's a worthy cause it's
amazing cause I stopped making fun of
her yes any more she's a she's doing
great things she's a good person
you know and I mean like I don't know
that family personally so you know I
could never really speak on them but for
someone to come out and actually because
there's so many people that are behind
bars yeah because of some stuff being
wrongfully accused and the fact that she
a celebrity like her of her stature is
really shedding light on that and
actually taking the steps to to go out
and actually help some of these guys
it's just amazing it's amazing and then
speaking of my father like I said like
this is no accident that we're here like
like life is this is no accident Joe but
like the last time I was here you know
was the first time I ever talked about
it and open up about it and this
attorney great touch out of South
Florida actually contacted means like
hey you know I would love to take a look
at the case and you know look at what's
going on here
and so you know he's kind of been like
looking into it working on it and you
know sending the letters that I need to
be sent and making the calls I need to
be made and Joe the moment I just walked
in here and I'm this is no lie I just
showed you the text I just walked in
here and I'm in the bathroom and I get
the text that says he's gonna be
released soon that's incredible and it's
like that's incredible
you should bring him with you to the
White House I would definitely try out I
will definitely try you know wild that
would be ah man you know the big thing
to me that would mean so much to me is
that my dad front and center for my
fine having my dad come into the cage
and put that belt around me that that
would be there's these moments in life
that I call it like being floored and
that's just when my your heart hits the
floor and I think those moments arrived
and and it which is what for me when you
think about the pursuit of happiness
these are the definition of that is when
you can you can make your parents heart
hit the floor yeah by doing something
like doing something to where you
recognize so much to where they're
recognized for the work that they did
raising you the the good work that they
did you know whether it's when in the
you know uh Rhodes Scholar where this
one in a Nobel Peace Prize I can you
imagine as a parent watching your child
accomplish something great like that
feeling is a feeling that I longed for
yeah I'm long I want I want to make my
parents feel that as many times as
possible before they're called home and
they pass from this earth and and I'm
sure my daughter at one point is gonna
want to do that and you know I think
when in that title and I would have
loved to see my dad's face when I won
that title and just and he's just look
into him and see how he felt so I can't
I can't wait for him to be at the next
one I can't wait for him to actually
feel that how long has he been locked up
for I think since 2009 11 years I
think yeah and my dad did miss beat -
thank you go seeing my dad's the same
guy well is the same guy you would think
this is something I would defeat
somebody that would crush them and kill
him and of course I'm not with him day
in and day out but my dad's still the
same guy to me and so uh man a you know
I'm not gonna cry but I can't I can't
wait for him I can't wait for him to
actually hold my dad again if you could
choose who would you like to see him
caged side when you fight who would you
like to be fighting when he's there for
the first time if I could choose if you
could choose would it be red panties
[Laughter]
right there I don't know how you listen
to me Connor can get it too but you know
at the same time it's it's his choice
Connor is work to get to the point where
if Connor decides I want to get my ass
kicked by Huisman that's his choice you
know he has the right to make that
decision because he's put himself in
that position you know but it's not a
fight that I'm gonna beg for that I
really want but I think someone brought
it after my last fight that I'm sitting
at right under George's record from most
consecutive wins in the welterweight
division and I think I'm like one behind
and so I think imagine me breaking that
record fighting the guy that has the
record that that would be insane I think
besides Connor that's the biggest fight
to actual to the other the other biggest
fight to make is could be if could be
decided to go up to 170 yeah I would
never fight could be really yeah that's
that's my brother I you know it's just
it's just like a mutual respect where I
I don't see myself ever I don't see
myself ever fighting khabib I don't see
myself ever fighting Israel you know
even though a lot of people kind of be
hinting towards it they're like yeah you
just need to fire you guys me if I don't
see myself fighting them you know
there's plenty of you having to yeah
plenty of people having two belts in 90
years better than just having one guy
holding two belts yeah are we saying yes
and so yeah there's no there's no desire
that I mean that's that's my guy I'm a
giant fan of him Oh Mike everything
about everything is Alerus personality
he could be a huge huge stupid Superstar
globally oh he will be I think he will
be he really could he really could mean
he's got everything first of all his
striking is some of the most intricate
complex and creative striking I've ever
seen just flew angles of gluon yeah just
wait switch stances and sets you up and
these traps and yes and I'm and I'm a
fan of I'm a fan of a lot of UFC
fighters almost every you like a UFC
fighters I'm a fan of especially now
getting into the analyst work - mm-hmm
like I get to actually have to watch
some of these guys that are just making
their debuts and things like that so I'm
a fan of a lot of these guys not just
the champions
and you know Israel is is he's special
he's buddies and I get kind of envious
I'm like damn I wish I could do that
I wish I could do this with my
hands around the way he does it in the
way he you know throws this little that
little question mark cake and the I'm
I'm a fan of these guys and Israel is is
one of those guys that's special and
Saint Francis I'm a fan of Francis I
want to be able to swing at somebody
even if the punch doesn't land they fall
over I want to be able to have power
like that Francis is powers preposterous
it doesn't make sense it's preposterous
[Applause]